I'm not sure that I know whether or not
think we're getting more faithful
because if people sign survey saying I'm
more faithful are they more faithful I
don't know I certainly hope that we
become more ethical because you know
we've always lived without any
boundaries in this country and i believe
the boundaries are going to be extremely
obvious in the next few years you know
it's it's the reason why I think I give
my I view myself as having at least a
shred of credibility is when I remember
talking to one of these be vastly
careless hanging from scott Fitzgerald
vastly careless repelling Republican
matriarchs talking to her about these
problems that I saw back in 2006 and
being poo pooed by her and many other
people that you know I know in fairfield
county and i finally decided hey you
know i'm not going to try to convince
you anymore i'm gonna make money off of
you so i found the right hedge fund guys
to start basically expecting the demise
of the US financial system because
what's built on a tissue of lies cannot
be stable I don't believe we've changed
things I don't believe we have a solid
foundation for a lot of future growth I
think things are really still messed up
and we're no and we're not admitting it
and so I believe we're going to have a
lot more problems so unless we do get a
lot more ethical we start asking what we
can contribute to society is supposed to
take I think this country is in real
trouble